tesla's ceo elon musk is officially the
richest person ever with a net worth of
271.3 billion dollars he achieved the
feat monday as tesla stocks soared after
hertz announced plans to buy 100
thousand electric vehicles for its
rental car fleet
the hertz fueled surge boosted tesla's
market cap north of one trillion dollars
much of musk's wealth comes from his 23
stake in tesla which saw its share price
jump from
909.68 a share at friday's close to
1024.86 a share at close monday
musk also benefited from 16 million new
stock options worth 16.1 billion dollars
awarded following tesla's latest
earnings report that show the car maker
notched record net income of 1.6 billion
dollars in the third quarter
musk's rise in wealth has been
staggering for comparison amazon's
founder jeff bezos became the richest
person to ever appear on the forbes 400
ranking of america's richest people
earlier this month topping the list with
an estimated 201 billion dollar fortune
musk is so rich he's worth more than
google co-founder larry page and
facebook ceo mark zuckerberg combined in
the united states only apple microsoft
amazon and google parent alphabet are
worth more than tesla
the hertz deal represents the largest
ever order for electric vehicles and it
will bring about 4.2 billion dollars in
revenue to tesla according to bloomberg
currently tesla is awaiting for approval
in germany to begin building vehicles at
its new giga berlin factory and will
soon begin production at its gigafactory
texas near austin
the addition of both facilities should
boost its global production footprint by
more than 50 in 2022 musk also has a
stake in privately held spacex which was
most recently valued by investors at 74
billion dollars following a february
funding round
[Music]
you